I think there's a value in going to a practitioner who looks at your live blood.
I think it may be called microscopy.
It's called dark field microscopy or live cell microscopy.
There is pros and cons to it.
So first of all, it's highly illegal in many states.
The reason is not always wrong because a lot of dark field microscopy practitioners, it's something you have to be fairly skilled at in order to really get a good reading.
I think there's a lot of value in it.
I think there's benefit to it, but it's not going to...
I don't know how much information you're going to get off it at this time.
You certainly can go and get tested. It's not very expensive.
And you could get a look at it.
Like a bit of soda, you can't do that under even as lay person.
You could get people that throw it in jail.